the american society of breast cancer
researchers a breast surgeon excuse me
is meeting right now in las vegas
several breast cancer survivors and
advocates will take part in the
conference together they're making
strides to help patients and their
families denise valdez talks with a
survivor about promising developments in
today's buddy check
under one roof there's surgeons
clinicians patients all talking about
the latest research and treatment for
breast cancer but also survivorship what
life is like before during and after
diagnosis mother writer and survivor
jennifer douglas is an advocate for the
well-being of patients and no two
stories are alike breast cancer is not
one disease there are many many
different subgroups during the
conference douglas is working alongside
mali surgical a medical device company
launching a program called hope
help optimism positivity empowerment
it's a collection of interviews support
services including a weekly facebook
chat all geared to help navigate through
treatment comprehensive collection of
resources that help the patients make
the best decisions
about their care
during this process patients are often
eager to learn about what they have and
how to treat it once we get past the
overwhelm we want to learn what is right
for me what do these
surgical options mean and so having
resources available that are from
clinicians who actually do the practice
from patients who've been there
really helps us as we're trying to make
our decisions douglas caught her dcis
breast cancer during her second
mammogram of her life
so she's become an advocate for regular
screenings as
much as we want to put these things off
mammograms really do when you get them
regularly they detect those changes and
then
we as patients have more options when
those changes are detected early so
that's why we remind you on the eighth
of every month to call or text your
buddy and make sure they do their breast
self exam and schedule that annual
mammogram denise valdez live local now